all right staying with Madness in the
public school system CBS news reports on
efforts to make math more Equitable
let's watch
this Pittsburgh Public Schools hiring a
consultant to teach a new method of
instructing kids it's intended to be
anti-racist and what some find Curious
is that the subject involved is math KDK
lead investigator Andy Sheen talked with
the district leader who recommended it
no matter how math is taught 1+ one will
always equal too the Pittsburgh Public
Schools is now offering what it calls an
anti-racist approach saying it is trying
to address ratio inequity in math
classes we think of math as you know
addition subtraction multiplication sort
of an objective reality how can math be
racist we're talking about really a
mindset and it's an approach so whether
we use the term anti-racist or we talk
about um racial Equity it's it's it's
the same last week the school board
approved a $50,000 contract to the
Consulting Group quetzel to provide
workshops for district Math teachers to
more fully engage students of color in
learning math and hopefully improve
performance according to the most recent
test scores 11.6% of the district's
African-American grade students scored
proficient in math compared to
47.5% of white students the district has
long sought to close that Gap and says
it will now be taking this approach it's
one thing to say that you know
African-American students in the in the
district are un
underperforming it's another thing to
say that the instruction by Math
teachers is racist we don't use um any
language to call any approach racist but
what we do is we talk about approaches
that are anti-racist okay pause it there
for a second so you notice with these
they can just never answer anything
directly
um on the left no it's it's not just
what is a woman or what is a man as we
discovered with our friend Jack Brewster
uh it's any question at all any any any
question relating to
their any any item on their
agenda they can never answer it directly
never answer a direct question they
refuse to answer direct questions um and
it's not because they don't have an
answer in mind it's not because they
don't know the answer it's because they
realize that fundamental their agenda
is is absurd and insane and extreme and
so they can't answer it
directly so clearly what the whole idea
here is that is that math education is
racist and so it needs to be anti-racist
and then he's asked
directly well how
exactly is could math education be
racist well we're not saying it's racist
but we're saying it should be
anti-racist well first of all it is kind
of what you but but earlier in the
discussion he did indicate that racist
and now he's saying it's well it's not
racist but it needs to be anti-racist so
but what's the opposite of anti-ra so
it's not anti is it right now it is not
anti-racist so if it's not anti-racist
does that mean that it's racist like
what just ex explain it in more detail
and he can't do that let's keep watching
a little bit of this to assistant
superintendent Dr Shawn mcneel this
means addressing historic inequities in
educating students by exposing them to
Black Professionals in stem field
to tell students of the African-American
Legacy in mathematics emphasizing its
practical applications in a Hands-On
welcoming way and McNeil says the
emphasis is on Concepts and reasoning
rather than putting importance on
getting the answer right is this not
sort of dumbing down the curriculum C
the math curriculum to say hey uh you
know all
right you know every time I see stories
like
this I have a few reactions I mean my
first reaction is is is that this is
crazy uh but then I always have there's
a little I have to admit I'll will admit
a little tinge of envy that I feel with
every time I hear about something like
this a little tinge of Envy um that they
didn't have policies like this in place
when I was in school I I would have
loved if uh when I was taking math
classes and Performing very poorly in
them I would have loved if they had a
policy that well we're not really
emphasizing getting the answer right I
would have I would have really
appreciated that when I was in school
you know 25 years ago I could have
really used that instead of it would
have helped who knows where I'd be today
I mean it would have helped my
self-esteem tremendously rather than
getting all those D's and E on math uh
on on math tests if they could have said
look uh you didn't get yeah there were
50 questions on this math test you got
precisely none of them correct uh but
we're not you know this is not this is
not about getting them right or wrong
that's not what this is about Grand
Canyon University is an affordable
private Christian University based in
Phoenix Arizona they're dedicated to
making education fit into your already
busy schedule which is why they offer
270 of their academic programs online
from scholarships to academic support
GCU graduation team provides you with
the personal support you need to obtain
your goals gcu's online programs offer
you the freedom to earn your degree on
your own time from wherever you are GCU
is praised for its culture of community
giving and impact they integrate the
free market system and a welcoming
Christian worldview into all of their
academic programs achieve your goals
with a personalized plan and supportive
team behind you find your purpose at
Grand Canyon University private
Christian affordable visit gcu.edu
that's gcu.edu since the overturning of
roie way the left has lost their minds
leftism is their religion and abortion
is their official Sacrament meanwhile
pro-life efforts which are now more
important than ever are booming despite
the narrative Pro lifers haven't gone
away in fact they're getting more and
more active as one of the largest prif
organizations in the world no one's in a
better position than 40 Days for life to
end abortion state by state they've
opened a record number of locations
since row was overturned and they
continue to grow in volunteers they now
have 1 million Volunteers in 1500 cities
40 Days for life holds peaceful vigils
outside abortion facilities in an effort
to change hearts and Minds in the most
blue pro-abortion States you can help 40
Days for Life fight ongoing legal
battles to protect free speech for their
volunteers by giving a tax deductible
gift of any amount at 40 days
forlife.com that's 40 days forlife.com
at the very least I wish ID thought of
this myself
as a an excuse that I could have
presented to my own parents when I came
home with the report card and said look
I don't want you to think too much about
whether the answers are right or wrong
it's not about right or wrong you know
it's not about it's not about grades Mom
and Dad it's about a journey that's what
it is it's about it's you know I'm on
the educational journey and I'm and I'm
really and I feel good about it I don't
know I don't know if that would have
resonated with them but what you have to
the real point with this is that aside
from just mocking it as we should um
that
mathematics is sort of like the LA the
last
stronghold if they can do this with math
then they can do it with anything if you
could take mathematics and and and and
start claiming that it's racist and that
we have to fundamentally change our
approach to it we have to make if if if
if we are at the point of making math
equitable
then
uh then that that's it that's the last
one like that math mathematics you would
think is as objective of a subject as
there can possibly be like 2 + 2 equals
4 it just does there's there's no way
around
it um and yet even with mathematics now
they're doing it um because ultimately
we we understand that this is more than
anything uh a war on Truth a war on
objective truth and that includes 2 plus
2 equals 4 thanks for checking out this
video if you'd like to listen to my full
podcast on the go you can check out the
Matt wall show on Apple podcast Spotify
or wherever you get your podcast